okay hi everyone we are doing another
open language design review for the 13.3
release
we are talking about the foreign
function interface mechanism and an
attempt to remember what we're talking
about before let's take a look at this
uh
okay that's more detailed than okay so
let's take it from the top okay so okay
so basically last time we renamed a few
things about foreign function load and
foreign function etc etc that's all been
done we also the main thing we did was
before there was all these you know
buffer to list lists to buffer string to
buffer functions Etc that's now all been
moved into these what like six functions
for import raw memory export raw memory
read write raw memory allocate and free
raw memory
um actually it's import and not read
there's also read read is the lower
level lower level one that lets you like
you know read from an offset like if
you're reading from an array import is
the higher level one that you want 90 of
the time okay so let's see what this
does here so foreign function load
round bytes is the internal C function
this is the path this is the signature
is that correct yep
that seems very lovely
and
returns a foreign function okay now if I
want to run that foreign function what
do I do
you just apply it like sub values okay
so if I take percent three
and I saw Rand bytes and I've bought as
it takes let's see it takes a raw
pointer a raw pointer right so look to
look two lines down okay so the next
line is generating the buffer that you
need to feed into it and then actually
you know what let's do a more minimal
example just if you want to do the
simplest thing just just on a new line
yeah you know uh and maybe you can try
and write it yourself in in compiler
demo base
that's the name of the library quotes
compiler demo base there's a function
called add one that just takes it into
and returns an INT
demo based like this uh lowercase C but
yes
b c
compiler
it's it's somewhere there's a
compilerdemo based.dy live okay all
right
and that is a foreign function of some
kind no that's a library like run find
library of that
okay
okay so you're going to load a function
from that called add one
okay so I say foreign
function load from that thing
is it like this how's it uh all
lowercase add one
okay let's see if it takes an intern or
returns an end okay so it's just list CN
does it need the list on the left hand
side yes
okay there it goes
and now I said percent of 89
whoopee doodle do
that's lovely
okay I get it so now for this one I have
to actually deal with pointers right you
have to make the arguments
so in this example so allocate raw
memory it has either be given a single
argument which is just a type and it
will allocate one of them or it can
allocate more click here
so question
what
what does this mean so should this be I
mean is really is managed object
generically the right term
okay so this is one of the things this
was going to be the second or third
thing that we talked about so there's a
little bit of complication around so
it's okay basically this is the right
thing for it to return almost all the
time there are some cases where you
don't want the managed object
um right now although I think this
should probably change there's an option
called memory managed Arrow true false
it defaults to true if you set it to
false it returns just a raw pointer
without the managed object around it
this breaks the rules about options not
changing the heads of the return type
the return
so they're either quite complicated
options that involve essentially
duplicating the same behavior but hiding
a bunch of the memory management inside
of the pointer object which the more I
think about it the more I think is a bad
idea
another option is to just get rid of the
memory management option functions like
allocate raw memory would then like
always return a managed thing
why would you want the raw points
yeah but I mean if I feed Rand bytes if
I want a raw pointer without management
right why would I want that
um if you for example are you know
handing over ownership of it to some
other code right like if for example I'm
maybe I'm allocating some memory but
it's going to be essentially owned by
some external program for a while and
you know I don't want to necessarily
have to keep references to the original
expression around
if you were using wftp you wanted to
pass the memory to wsdp you might want
the actual
but why not just pass it as a managed
object and wstb can strip the the
management exposing the wstp didn't do
that you're right yes but supposing it
didn't well no no I mean most all the
functions in ffi
fine yeah absolutely right right the
more important case the the case when
you wouldn't want when you'd want an
unmanaged pointer it's like I'm trying
to think of an example with a real
Library here but like you know there are
situations where
right there are situations where for
example you have to allocate memory
um but then the library is going to tell
you when you have to free it as opposed
to you figuring out when to free it by
reference counting because this is just
reference counting expressions in
in the language I see I see so so what
you're saying is there could be external
this is Management in our ecosystem yeah
you're saying there could be external
management which in fact where you in
fact don't want even if the reference
count went to zero in our ecosystem you
don't want it to free because it
actually has an external tentacle for
example yes
but so why not have part of the managed
object be something that says where are
the tentacles because it's it's like in
general you you just can't know right I
mean like in general there can be
arbitrary tentacles like that's why we
have free raw memory which is the
function for freeing it if it's not
already memory managed
oh it's not it's not already in a
managed object well so may I make a
suggestion maybe what we should do is
the option to allocate raw memory could
contain something that says it is a
managed object but by managed it means
it still might have a tentacle missing
and therefore don't free it
where is known as not a managed object
well fair enough
here's the one of the ideas right from
like the last couple days is uh habits
that allocate raw memory always returns
a managed object but then if you want an
unmanaged object you use the function
unmanage object on it which is an
existing function for compiler only
stuff
um but which we already talked about
using for this and basically what that
function will do is it it diffuses
managed object so that you know yeah
they'll no longer uh actually free the
thing
that sounds reasonable to me
and a very small name even for it that
function I assume it Returns the inner
value right it doesn't definitely okay
yeah
what is the difference between a value
and a payload
this is a kind of subtle thing so for
example take that if you say um
uh
right basically you can have two managed
objects who sort of represent slightly
different values but which need to share
a reference count so here's an example
um that's a that's a managed object to a
raw pointer of a you know unsighted
straight if you ever have a raw pointer
you can always run raw pointer around
that and give it a different type to
essentially cast so try running raw
pointer of out comma
you know some other type other than
unsigned integer 8.
I don't know let's say real 32 or
something yeah so the point is that this
goes you know through the managed object
they cast the internal thing but
this still
like
this has to share a reference count with
the one I understand I understand I
understand is payload the right term for
that
I don't know
okay hold on let's think about this so
I've resumed this also just to add a
case if you were to do something like
you know index eight bytes after a
particular pointer about that yes yeah
that that will be the value right now we
don't have a function for doing that but
but we maybe could
the value could be that but the the
I mean to me
this would be rather than calling it
payload it would be raw data or
something is this
so so I think it's more like it's more
like the root of the ownership tree or
something right because you might you
know you could do this multiple times
where
you're indexing you know eight bytes a
headache bytes of headache bytes ahead
but there's still something that's like
ultimately what was this derived from
well the way this actually works if you
run input form of that although this is
a little bit broken right now
um basically this actually works is that
the managed object
oh okay never mind it's it's too broken
to even see right now basically there's
actually two levels there's the outer
managed object which contains the value
and then there's this inner managed
object which contains the payload and
the reference count and basically you'll
have many outer managed objects with
different values that all refer to the
same kind of inner object that makes
sense
well I would just call it then I would
call it raw object or something down at
the bottom under rather than payload
it's the managed object right there's
the outer wrapper and then the thing
underneath is the raw object or the base
object or the base yeah I think
yeah like base something along those
lines better captures what that actually
is because what you really want to
understand when you look at that is this
is a derived thing which is derived from
some other thing which you have to
reason about when you're trying to
figure out okay sounds reasonable to me
crystal what do you think
that's fine
um
yeah I mean it's basically let me see
right I mean the thing that's like the
value of the the managed object is
essentially you know the value that it
represents in the sense that you know
you would imagine that like you want to
be able to treat this managed object as
if it were as if it were its value
and then this other thing that what
we're now calling the base object is is
the thing that actually that the freeing
function gets applied to when it's time
to free it
so I think the words
go ahead
oh sorry yeah go ahead Connor well I
also visually like the freeing function
doesn't group with the value it groups
with the base object right because
that's ultimately what that freeing
function has to get called on I assume
yeah foreign
yeah I mean I wonder if that shouldn't
be some
if that shouldn't be one field that's
you know base object that inside of it
has the freeing function and well you
want to be able to display the frame
function here that's very useful and the
Very fact that it has the bringing
function tells you something about what
the hell this thing is
I was thinking that what we could do
might be to not have that label value
colon just have the managed object and
then it would line up nicer there just
have the manage object just say managed
object of raw pointer and then freeing
function and then it's got the other
stuff
let me just get rid of the value colon
later yeah because I don't think the
value colon is doing much for us I guess
um I'm not sure if summary boxes support
that but I can check well anyway why
don't we see if that can be done yeah um
if it can't be done then
never know string I suspect
yeah well
yes would it still still show the colon
though there
okay
um
this is nice otherwise I mean okay
can we keep going I think this looks
good to me
so you can see if you there's an example
piece of code which is analogous to for
example that you probably don't remember
uh to Generate random bytes so that's
like I think I've packaged everything up
that's what I remember like I remember
that I remember that we went through it
and this is much cleaner right and note
the import raw memory also so basically
it's it's somewhat analogous to any of
the other import export things it takes
the format in the second argument
although the format is nothing to do
with the import export format list
it's its own list which you can find in
the docs
I'm sorry excuse me what would you just
say could you I was just saying that the
second argument of import raw memory is
is is not an import export format like
the other ones it's its own list of
import export formats
look
some of these docs are more real uh
memory not bytes
from memory yeah
it's at work no
you have to use the docu tools
there you go
okay
looks nice
a white can't you do I mean like if you
wanted to import a struct or something
could you do that with yes so so right
so so the the pointers are always type
annotated so if it was a pointer to a
struct type then you could actually just
use read raw memory which assumes that
it's you know an array of one element
kind of thing yeah so these are using
what are effectively top level types
whereas read rule memory is effectively
using what are effectively compiler
types is that right
uh no like it's it's so for example
import raw memory with list
um is doing basically redraw memory
except it will do more than one of them
what is the right way to think about
uh whether the type is specified in the
object versus in the second argument to
the importing function so the right so
basically
the pointers that you feed to import is
are always type annotated so they always
know what what basically the element
type is because these are basically all
array types
um so the the format for import raw
memory is only telling you what is it
being converted into
like it's telling you what what's the
Wolfram language representation you want
to get back not what is the kind of
thing you're pointing at
okay and presumably there's some table
there mapping
from you know if you try to import a c
struct as a byte array you get an error
it knows that I can't do that conversion
okay yes
actually for some of them
yeah for some of them I intentionally
didn't have some error handling because
their cases where for example
um I mean arguably you can just do
casting
right where uh you know you might say oh
well I know it's a I know it's an
integer but I just want to bite array
anyway
I wonder I mean is that I'd worry about
things like padding it's and I don't
know
offsets kind of
screwing that up in weird ways that
might not be obvious I wonder if it
shouldn't do error detection by default
but perhaps have some you know some kind
of allow
casting option that you could set to
true the defaults to false to disable
that kind of error checking yeah like
suspicious cast checking
maybe yeah I don't remember exactly
which things had error handling which
didn't or like which things had had type
checking essentially
um
I think if any of them don't it's
basically just the byte array one
sorry you're saying can this Auto cost
can import raw memory Auto costs right
the question is if I have a pointer to
an INT and I ask it to be I'd like you
know imported as a string that should
fail because it's like well I only know
how to convert Char stars to Strings I
don't know how to convert into stars to
strands right but if you say something
like give me uh you know here's a an
inch star give me a byte array of length
10. then it is unambiguous what you've
got to do yeah I don't know why you
can't do it I mean you could import a I
mean you would you would import you know
because it's an alternated string it's
it's not going to even terminate it's
going to start snapping in random pieces
of memory
yeah I I think this is a fairly low
stakes
question but yeah I I think I either way
I think it's
I could be that slow today but
I'm curious what would if you have like
an inst Star as the memory and you did
import raw memory of byte array comma
10.
I think it does a byte array of length
10 not 10 integers worth of bytes
like that so if like an integer is four
bytes it reads the first integer the
second integer and the first two bytes
of the third integer and that's what it
returns okay depending on it's Indian
Mist it will
get whatever it gets that's why there's
a raw in the name right okay that makes
sense
does is there any sense of endiness by
the way in any of this stuff of if
you're reading across I I have no I have
no idea what's that frankly I have no
idea yeah okay fine I mean because we
have an end in this don't we have a
variable that represents the end in this
in
in uh read
you know in some of the binary read
functions
between things of different sizes that
that really matters yeah if you bitcast
in a row of ends to an array of bytes
you'll see that difference but if you
read them sequentially then then then it
you know
figures them out
does it I mean for an integer well
anyway never mind it's a detail let's
not worry about it okay let's look at
the second example here that example is
quite similar it's just a little more
complicated
it's using export raw memory though
which is nice
so export raw memory is kind of similar
to import except that so first of all it
can automatically often determine what
it's doing okay you give it a string
it'll assume it should turn into an
ultra terminated chart star
um sorry I have a very detailed point
the fact that this doesn't wrap and just
sort of truncates in this weird way is
there any way we can do better than that
we could use the better Syntax for colon
code you know type specifier that would
make well right that that's a different
thing which I think we should do anyway
which is just that right right now we
have a nice import form for type
specifier which you can see in the
import there but it doesn't format like
that in output which it really should oh
it should we should just change that we
really should just change it for input
form everything we should just change it
to use that I don't think anybody wants
to see the type specifier version
does that make sense let's just go ahead
and change it even down to level input
form
and that will vastly improve it might
have some hairy consequences for 13-3 it
would be better to do it
immediately after the code you know in
the next version well look at least for
this output it's not a problem that
could be done differently I think yeah
okay fine
okay so hold on that you're saying this
has
a raw pointer which returns a raw
pointer here
and it takes the raw pointer and then
returns a raw pointer yeah
so that exports raw memory makes a
managed object that exports more raw
memory makes managed object
then this runs it let's what should
happen
I didn't run the foreign function of it
yeah
lovely
cool and now if you import the raw
memory where it wrote the buffer
then you'll get back
the hash but what about this thing here
what's that oh that's I mean you have to
look up the docs for open SSL to know
what that is but I can tell you I think
it's just the buffer again
yeah if you look at the pointers it's
just the buffer that you put in again
now make a suggestion though could you
not have some way of giving
documentation in this foreign function
thing just some basic does that make any
sense I have no idea what you mean no
well I mean to have in the summary Blob
why not have descriptions of these
arguments
that you can optionally give that appear
in the summary blob or because otherwise
it's like where do you go for this
documentation
okay let me make it you have to go I
mean like right like
foreign function load could support
something like annotation or labeled or
something along those lines on those
arguments why don't we do that for Wolf
and language functions
because we don't have an external
wrapper that that loads them but I mean
like why can't you annotate the uh the
arguments in your in your set delayed
let's let's have a discussion in I'll be
about that
you probably should be able to do that
okay I'm careful with your hypotheticals
Christopher
um but but in this case at least getting
a something that is like what we have
for resource function where you know
because if I do a resource function or a
net net model let's say
you know of G I mean I think the thing
is though is it's just I mean
you know
realistically the thing you need to do
if you want to understand this is read
open ssl's documentation I know I know
so I'm making gonna make a suggestion
see this here
oh God we have got to fix this thing
where it escapes do you see this I move
down and it runs away
whoever's project management
I remind John fultz that's the top
priority thing to fix this because I
don't know how to chase the raft
right everybody's gonna have drown
nobody's going to be able to find the
raft
or the tongue or whatever it is
yeah this one's a raft I think but
whatever yeah but okay the main point is
that I button opens external
documentation
I know that but but why not just provide
a URL that it can open
just so that you're not left so the
thing is I have no idea how you'd pre
where you'd ever get such an object if
that makes sense like even if you were
parsing header files like like I'll post
in the chat there's the relevant
documentation right I don't know where
you'd find that URL it won't be in the
header files it won't be you know no I
understand it's you as a human have to
find it right but that's like the amount
of I just think no one will ever do that
really
yes like I've done I've done examples
with this like you're importing you know
dozens to a hundred foreign functions
and making a big link like this you're
not gonna
you know and you have to return my
reading the external documentation
anyway so it's really not that useful
okay all right I mean you could make a
link to it's just like where does the I
is there an i button and if not well
there isn't an i button
yeah yeah
so okay I mean it just seems to me if
there was an i button you could link it
off to one of these you know to it just
feels like it just feels like oh if
you're calling you know
I don't know you're calling import from
you know you you are URL reading from an
API you know maybe there should be some
way of of getting the apis documentation
it's kind of like you know
yeah all right you just have it open in
another tab this is how you do it okay
fair enough any other systems to be more
complicated way of doing that where did
this come from and so on whatever I I'm
I'm not good well it does know about
what library it's from if you press the
plus button it might probably even says
although it might be a bit ornate yeah
lib crypto
how do I see that
the library field oh at the end yeah
actually I think it does if you give it
a shorter
um
I'm not sure if it actually no I think
that is post find library what it shows
there is always post find Library
okay
okay let's keep going here
yeah well so that's my point is not as
completely stupid as you're making it
out to be that there's some kind of URL
that can be associated with a foreign
function which just tells you gives you
a fighting chance to be able to find out
what the hell it is I mean the thing is
even even popular libraries often don't
even have uh like documentation like
that on the web fine so it's it's
by the way with Stefan responding to the
the escaping raft about we have bug
reports it's not good enough to have bug
reports this is something that there's a
there's a
there's a bug report uh I mean there's a
pull request open with a fix that's in
review all right okay fine that's what I
wanted to hear
okay
so okay
so that that's basically all the
examples so now we're basically caught
alcohol okay um oh boy so that was okay
right and it's blindingly fast wonderful
yeah okay so
um so first okay just for reference
there's a list of symbols we don't need
to go through it yet so right here if
you're the outstanding questions though
so the first one is is null pointer
queue this is a trivial function that
just takes opaque raw point if you give
it a pay crop pointer of zero it returns
true or raw pointer of zero comma
whatever returns true everything else
returns false
so that's what it's called right now
it's called null pointer queue the
argument for the raw is just that uh you
know the functions that make them are
the raw memory functions we have to and
from raw pointer in the compiler yeah
everything else is raw
well okay
basically every symbol that includes the
word pointer right now has it as raw
pointer so this is
is that stupid raw no
well no it's like it adds to others but
it breaks the consistency right like
like the other ones are opaque raw
pointer and drop pointer right so those
the raw and the points are never
separated
so I see so you're saying null raw
pointer queue
yeah all right okay I agree the whole
point of Q is more consistent
okay fine I think yeah I'm not sure
which way it should go but I think
that's fine
okay memory managed option we discussed
that right yeah so the answer there is
to just is just to to not have the
option if you want a a non-memory
managed one you call unmanage object
yourself
manage object on this list
uh it's not because it's already in the
compiler it's a compiler only thing but
for a similar purpose for yeah for a
quite simply it has the same semantics
essentially for in the compiler but has
no top level Behavior right now
and
foreignly it says unmanaged object is
only available in compiled code
right yeah and it would it would have a
return value in the case of a managed
object
yeah which is almost identical to what
it does in the compiler right now
exactly yeah
um the only difference right now I mean
this is this is one thing it's a little
annoying but it's not this is a more
complicated thing though I don't think
we'll be able to resolve right now is
that the compiler managed type
um
does not have the same payload value
mechanism that the managed object does
in the top level
what does it do does it have a different
way of handling costs
it basically doesn't have a mechanism
for handling cast you basically have to
you know have just one copy of it like
you'll have to unmanage one and then
make a new version with a different type
or whatever
right
okay
but but yeah
um
all right so so the uh right and we
already talked about last time
supporting unmanaged object unmanaged
object for
the managed objects in the top level so
yeah that's something we're gonna do
anyway sorry that sounds fine okay so
the last one is this
um
a function that needs a name and you
know
there's a question of whether it should
exist at all but I think it should so
this is basically
um
right how to describe this okay so when
you when you you've DL opened some
Dynamic Library
um
basically when you DL Sim is then the
function for getting function pointers
right so like if I want to say give me
the address of this function you call DL
Sim right so basically what DL Sim does
is you give it the name of a symbol and
it says this is the address here's a
pointer to where that symbol has been
loaded but by symbol here you mean
symbol in the sense of a Linker not
symbol in the sense of an expression
correct which is very confusing but so
so the the basic right so the point is
that that can be used for basically you
can use that to get the address of a
function pointer but without loading it
as a foreign function object that's a
quite marginal use the thing that this
is useful for is globals
because you can also have Global Dynamic
libraries and this is how you load them
oh my God so you'd say the same
basically foreign
pointer load you give it the library in
the name it would give you an okay crawl
pointer and then you'd use raw pointer
to cast that to whatever it actually is
okay but in this case
I mean to me I think it has to be name
not symbol I mean it could say something
like foreign name pointer
right that's fine does it also work for
functions
yes they're names too
so you can read the address of the phone
I'm I'm not saying you're but let's
understand exactly what's in it okay so
you give it
you can try that one there's an
implementation if you try that thing
with the long name below you can see
what it was like although there's a few
error handling things you can try the
compiler demo base and then add one as
an example
how do I do that compiler compiler demo
base the same as the example above
right because because functions are just
globals in the and then I just do like
this Library yeah run it
you'll notice actually if you say try
running information of ad1 Brad one is a
symbol that you defined above
oh or not oh no you just use percent
that's right okay well
What's it gonna show me
it's the same number that's what yeah
it's gonna show
I understand how it's got any number
oh yeah yeah
it is the address of the function yeah
okay so the issue is
somehow you've got a spelunk I mean this
is essentially a splunction function so
to speak
that's going to go into the symbol table
of
the library
yeah so maybe for for reference so on on
unixie things this is called DL SIM for
symbol on Windows I think this is called
get process address
and yeah I mean I wonder also if and I
don't know if this is possible to
implement but if there shouldn't be a
find
function analog of this where you can
search the symbol table for symbols that
match the string pattern
yeah I do another question how do I get
a list of all symbols
definitely doesn't they don't even
provide this this is just from the OS
and actually I'm getting this from some
kernel functions which give you this but
um I I think in general especially on
Windows you I'm not sure you can do that
like you can just get a list of the
entry points I I think so
um I think you're right Christopher yeah
I think Unix might have a mechanism for
it but it's like pretty bizarre and
there's this whole weird system for
um
like
right like I'm not sure you can
necessarily get the list of symbols
associated with a particular Library as
much as you can get the list of symbols
that are in your current process and you
can prioritize you know a particular
Library if that makes sense
I mean linkers know how to do this yeah
sure that's what their business is
yeah yeah I think it's a funky business
though and it works very differently on
windows so right right yeah and I think
for what it's worth I was just doing
some Googling it seems like there's
definitely no posix function to do this
there's no standard way to do it yeah
you're correct yes that's right yeah and
the answer is also need to be like if
you're on Linux you could try manually
parsing the elf headers
um and presumably similar such
manual parsing of object code on the
other platforms as well yeah yeah I mean
there's three there's three Library
formats remember as well okay yeah guys
guys guys guys
um
uh
what about something like named for an
object pointer
so two things one I like Forum being the
start because everything pretty much
everything else here starts with forum
okay
um
second I'm not sure the named
I'm not sure named is a useful term a
lot of things are named if that makes
sense
yeah but when you've got to do something
where where it's always a symbol which
is even more unbelievably confusing
yeah symbol I think is a bit too
confusing
so maybe it's object instead of but
foreign object load it's not really a
load is it it's not really an object
though especially neither an object nor
is it loading
well that's why that was the argument
for foreign pointer find
functions usually return a list though
don't they I mean
yeah and they also usually expect can
take various kinds of patterns what's an
alternative to find I mean
pointer address
that seems not useful well the pointer
is the address right yeah
or something or get foreign pointer but
I don't like the ordering of get first
but look up maybe
that's better that's not bad yeah it
could be it could be like foreign
Library
you know name lookup or something
so it's because it's operation on a
library ultimately foreign name lookup
it sounds like it's going to look up
like if you have some weird
Croatian name
yeah we have to remember that this is uh
um
well it's in a library right it's always
in a library
yeah
I mean foreign name Library lookup
none of these other things include the
word Library it's all kind of implied
and also the the thing we decide last
time or two times ago was that you know
there's the library load Library
function load Etc brand which is for
Library link and then these are foreign
X for the ffi system fair enough
I don't understand your point though
about the other things don't contain
libraries so this shouldn't either
why just me I mean first of all you know
the uh Library function load could be or
sorry foreign function mode could be
foreign Library function load or
something yeah exactly yeah yeah it's
implicit in foreign
symbol lookup
no we can't use the word symbol
it's totally confused yeah I do think
symbol is a bit too confusing and also
I'm not sure that uh Windows calls it a
symbol
how about I like look up foreign name
pointer lookup
or foreign what is the name yeah I think
foreign pointer lookup is better the
name I just don't think adds anything
fine foreign point to look up sounds
reasonable to me
yeah I I like that one you're looking up
a foreign it's looking up a pointer in
this foreign place yes based upon a key
right yeah
fine sounds good
and in some world of the future maybe it
could deal with a regex or something but
that's we don't know how to do that yet
nice okay that's basically it
these are just a few outstanding but it
is planning to do this right Christopher
like int regulars do things as well yeah
I that that one is a little I need to
look into that yeah the other ones here
are like yeah that so this is basically
something we talked about like two times
ago which is that instead of writing C
and T should be able to like instead of
running you know raw pointer colon colon
bracket CNT you should be able to write
in Star
um but that requires you know a bit of
parsing stuff and I don't know if
there's some complicated cases which it
presumably just won't handle Chris
Cooley have a puzzle that works against
those things didn't he build that at
some point
that's exactly what we need right like
I'm not sure if it's if it's you know if
there's a way of calling it to say I
only want to parse
you know type signatures well I believe
we had a type signature puzzle also move
from alpha at one point maybe we still
do I mean we have a link to Clan apis
which Chris has been transitioned into
using so it can do whatever plan can do
in terms of pausing although I I
remember looking at claim like years ago
and it's not trivial right and it's a
mess doing it through cleaning massively
not trivial I thought we did this I
don't know what What's Happening Here I
I thought maybe get rid of space
just in Star no space I mean this is how
we generate uh the link to llvm which
which has about a thousand functions in
it we we use Pangolin for that I think
at least for the zeroth version of this
I would probably just use string
patterns correct because we're not even
supporting that many
situations here
um
yeah I think the only minor concern
apart from the fact that it's it's a bit
of it's a bit you know it's not totally
trivial to do but the only minor concern
would be that people could be confused
because they'll have you know their very
some some type that only exists in their
environment and they'll be like why
hasn't this why doesn't this work with a
you know
uh I see with the shorter what's some
but even things like you know oh and c99
there's a thing called div T which is a
struct containing two ins that gets
returned by the div function you know
but like odds are we're not going to
support everything like div T so people
are going to be like oh you know
why have you never heard of this type
I mean eventually we need an interpreter
for C types and we'll get fancier about
that
yeah yeah but it's not just they're
truth points there's one yeah I agree
interpreter is probably the right way to
do it and it would return whatever's the
right you know raw pointers and stuff
like that right type specifiers but um
but separately there's the issue of like
if you go to
um foreign foreign function loads
documentation you can see a list of the
supported types
um and it's like obviously it doesn't
include div T
um you have to use you have to use the
document tools oh okay
thank you
okay so there's the list right
what will you say if they just say oh I
see if they just say enter it's done
well and so this is pretty string I mean
this is pretty straightforward string
patterns
and what about things like the array
specifications and see
it's that's worked a little more
annoying it should probably support
those two what are they when they're
disembodied when they don't have does
that have some tax when they don't have
a name
yeah I think you just say in bracket 20
I think
although I really remember this being
some weird stuff we're like no that's
not quite the same thing I mean that's
that's not a
yeah I mean that's
one of these things about c-types if
they can't actually they can't be
disembodied because there's this weird
winding rule
that I know that's function pointer
types at least where the name is kind of
a weirdly integral part of the
Declaration
actually I just I right so the the case
of like the the array like the inch
bracket 20. so right now the way we
represent an array like that is uh
is sort of funky I mean it's basically
it's the way that Liberty Phi does it
which is that you basically treat it as
like a struct with 20 fields
which I guess have the same padding and
stuff
um I mean this is just inherited from
the thigh
right
all right we should um
we should wrap it up here I have one
more thing I would like to bring up
which is about just a general thing
about naming we we have foreign function
law foreign function blah but the realm
memory stuff is all allocated on memory
import raw memory why don't we switch
those over to the noun verb style of
naming instead of verb now so wrong for
raw memory export yes and it just groups
so nicely that way you know all the
function stuff is done this way
so the only argument that the reason why
it was done in that order was because
uh the other import export things are in
this somewhat backward order as are like
binary read and binary right
binary right isn't in that order I know
I know writers in the order with binary
first
and import raw bytes does a different
thing oh no yes you're right you're
right import byte array
well import byte array is like import
raw memory but you could argue that raw
memory import is importing from a
different source
yeah it's really not that much like
import is it no I don't think it is yeah
I mean it doesn't have the import export
format but it does have important name
so so I'm guessing Okay so what would be
affected by this
I mean it will be raw memory input raw
memory export raw memory read raw memory
right actually those are quite nice
seems to me raw memory free
yes right every one of them would just
be flipped around to start with raw
memory
and they all group perfectly
I don't I don't hate that yeah
Christopher yeah I think that's fine
okay
good catch
create data structure and create like
there's a ton of names in the system
that are verb now nowadays they we're
mostly noun verb from in the old days
I just think that we should strive for
new namings to stick to the noun verb
style I think it's just what is foreign
callback again
that is uh let me see oh yeah I may
actually made an example for that
actually if you go to the docs for
create foreign callback there's an over
complicated example
create foreign callback yes right so why
isn't that foreign callback create
well because it's trying to look like
create data structure create type
instance and yeah but right if it's
parallel to other things then okay
so right so basically here's here's an
overcomplicated example that that
basically that code just needs to be in
compiler demo base but but yeah so
basically there's a function that takes
a function pointer
what uh create form callback basically
gives you a thing that can be
interpreted as a function pointer but
which internally calls evaluated code so
see that takes some noise it's nice so
look at the scroll down a teeny bit more
and you can see there's the foreign
callback that's just calling Echo
evaluation of you know hash squared in
it
you know it's running in your kernel
call for the C code it's pretty nice
right I mean maybe it should have a more
a more uh magnificent name
like
I mean this is the name we camped with
last time there was much discussion
about it foreign
from a piece of C code
but now
I see I see I see the way it has to work
is you define a piece of C code and if
you wanted the C code to be in charge
calling main then it's a different
pattern that in this case where the
where the Wolfram language system is in
charge loading a library which contains
C code which then calls back into orphan
language
right in other words if you wanted
something where fundamentally you would
execute from the command line through
the main yeah right then this does not
help you
right how do you do that what is the
best modern way of doing that
well you're describing a bit of the
Standalone application stuff I think
I see where you have a main program that
can call into this
I'm not sure if it's calling into this
exactly well known to the kernel in
general but yeah
right
I don't think this is useful for stuff
like um uh
right like a few examples like one
example would be something like in
sqlite or in postgres they have systems
for like if you have uh oh what is it
it's like if you have your own you can
have like weird functions that are
written in the query but which call out
arbitrary C code so here they can call
it to a kernel
um yes no that's great right that's
great for postgres for example with some
weird you know compute the bezel
function of this number
right excellent stuff all right looks
like a lovely system
um
all right anything else for right now
I don't think so okay otherwise I think
this is probably you know wrapped
wrapped yeah
good okay excellent work all right okay
the people on the live stream we're
about to go to different live stream
about Kafka and algebra seola
bye for now bye